normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government we
have this clip it was posted on Twitter
it's got half a million views lofty
pixel says Ethan breaks down on stream
after withstanding an unending barrage
of 30,000 cultists in Hassan's chat
spamming Hamas are resistance Fighters
and from The River To The Sea and
Zionist Pig perpetually for three
straight hours let me uh let me play
this clip for you guys sounds just like
they're Discord actually man and you
know not a radical Jew I'm not
even a religious Jew I have no I
have no stake in the game and this is
coming
from yeah it's still playing I know I
know Ethan uh is now he just gets up and
leaves so then we have another clip
there's there's a bunch of things that
have been posted this is uh the
quartering posted this 4 hours ago Ethan
kleim has Klein has epic meltdown after
Hassan calls him stupid to to his face
we'll play this out briefly saying black
lives matter doesn't insinuate that
other lives don't matter it's it's in
the phras bro I don't know what to tell
you the river to the Sea Palestine will
be free also doesn't feature from The
River To The Sea we should destroy
Israel and kill all the Jews you're the
one who's saying that that is the
secondary implication behind it well I I
I think that and then uh of course we
have this clip this is from too lazy to
try where he posts this clip we actually
I couldn't find this one I don't know
where he got this clip from but it's
Ethan Klein basically breaking this down
I'll play a little bit of this so you
can hear what he has to say Discord and
what I saw in that Discord was Universal
near Universal praise for
Hamas near Universal saying people
deserved it people near universally
calling me a Zionist Pig in Mass
murdering genocidal
freak and if you want to know the truth
that me up seeing that
Discord because
it made me realize
that a lot of these people are watching
this show and it frankly Disturbed me
listen everyone in my periphery everyone
in my circle all the leftists uh people
that I watch that I'm part of that watch
this show because I consider myself part
of that side are all pretty much
uncritically accepting of Hamas
propaganda and un caring about the Revis
rewriting of History right before ouring
eyes about this stuff so I'm not seeing
a lot of people even though you might
look at the popular media and say you
know everybody's supporting Israel this
is this is the this is the breakdown in
in pop culture and modern culture so
Ethan Klein for those that are familiar
he's got h3h they they've been big for a
really really long time he's got
millions of subscribers he has a big
show Hassan perer of course is the most
prominent leftist streamer they do a
show together called leftovers and now
they're they're feuding with each other
over this one we saw Amy Schumer posting
articles from campus reform which is a
conservative leaning publication we are
seeing mainstream celebrities being
fired from their jobs for supporting
Israel it is the weirdest thing to see
someone like you know what I I just got
to say this Ethan
kleene is married to a this is correct
Serge IDF veteran yeah she well everyone
in Israel has sered with the ID her name
is Ela yeah yeah and uh uh so
obviously he's Jewish he has connections
to Israel when he started working with
these other leftists I'm just look man I
I how do you not know the views of the
people you're working with this is not
new the leftist protests going back as
far as I know were in support of
palestin we're very critical of Israel I
feel like too many of these celebrities
just said I'll do whatever is popular
and now it's blowing up in their faces
because they ended up saying wait wait
wait hold on I can't can't support that
not to mention it's this really weird
circumstance where you do have massive
massive popular support for for
Palestine critical of Israel but you
have major corporations that aren't
having none of it a lot of these
celebrities are concerned they're going
to lose money they're going to lose jobs
they're going to get fired if they're
critical of Israel but at the same time
if you're supporting Israel you're
getting fired too so it's like double
cancel culture going on who's gotten
fired for supporting tar strong Tara
Strong she's a voice actress she got
fired without notification because she
was posting a bunch of stuff on on
Twitter like I stand with Israel people
were kidnapped and whatas is doing and
then they abruptly post saying we'll no
longer be working with her on the show
and she's like one of the most famous
voice
actresses EXC okay in the world I
haven't heard of that my whole life I've
seen people getting cancelled and
smeared and fired for criticizing Israel
so I mean no one should be fired for
their political views I still think
though the overwhelming trend is towards
targeting people for being critical of
Israel I I I do agree and I think that
that's why a lot of these celebrities
are just like uhoh this is why you're
seeing a lot of people on the left
calling out black lives matter now
because these leftist institutions these
or these activist organizations that are
critical of Israel Pro Palestine are
unabashedly coming out and saying like
nah we're we're we're in support of this
and then it comes to an extreme degree
where you have uh BLM Chicago posted the
paraglider you had AC um several rallies
in New York where the the activists were
actually cheering for Hamas explo
licitly and I'm not saying Palestine
they were saying things like those
hipsters you know got kidnapped and
taken I'm sure they're doing fine things
like that people are losing their jobs
for that for sure and now you you've got
those uh uh those uh what was it the uh
wall was it Wall Street investors
putting up a list of the people they
will not hire right they were saying
that there's certain universities they
won't hire from you have James Lindsay
going out there saying don't hire
college graduates which is fascinating I
mean he's saying that for all of his
very specific James Lindsay reasons not
just not like the Israel thing
but um yeah you're seeing a lot of that
the thing in New York um and the thing
with celebrities the thing with
celebrities I think that a lot of it
they were fine to
criticize um Israel and support
Palestinians because they simply didn't
have they simply didn't believe that an
attack like this would happen and so I
think this was like a visceral reaction
to this attack which is what like the
worst one since since the Holocaust
apparently it's like worse than the yam
kapor War um
there yeah go ahead when people say it's
worse than the Holocaust I'm like okay
well it's not worse than theoc it's like
the biggest yeah that's what they I'm
like okay okay but there's a
dramatic huge difference 1400 6 million
yeah and so you know look the issue here
is the only thing that I care about is
the zealotry is like you had uh one
individual who I won't name calling for
well not I I would okay I'll put it this
way she said the only reason reason not
to Nuke Gaza is because the Fallout
would affect Israelis and I'm like
that's insane and then you also have
people like BLM Chicago posting the the
the paraglider and I'm like y'all people
chill with well the rest what's
interesting about the BLM Chicago thing
is that was BLM Grassroots and BLM
National was very quick to distance
themselves from that group of course
they wouldn't have been last year Pat
Patrice cers has that famous line in
2015 where she said we must end what did
she call it end the I don't remember
remember seeing and the project or
whatever that is called Israel or or
something she called it yeah but in in
New York when you see activists pulling
down American flags and putting up
Palestinian flags and stuff that's not
um that's not a new sentiment in New
York that's a long I mean I lived in Bay
Ridge in in Bay rid Brooklyn for a long
time which is a very Arab neighborhood
uh you know I was often like the only
the only white person basically at the
grocery store um and that neighborhood
had Pro Palestinian marches and stuff
every couple of weeks every month or so
you would walk outside and see these big
gatherings of people opposing um
essentially opposing Israel and being
pro Palestinian and that's in a
neighborhood that's very Arab but it's
also like got a lot of Jews in that
neighborhood so I don't think I wasn't
that surprised to see that um erupt in I
was surprised at how many people there
were but that is a long-standing
sentiment coming out of Brooklyn for
sure you know putting inside the content
of pro Palestinian uh expression a lot
of which I would totally defend I still
think there's a huge power disparity
we're talking about what some activists
say or what some signs say when it comes
to the media when it comes to Congress
Rashida Talib just got censured for uh
endorsing the slogan from The River To
The Sea Palestine will be free which I
think is a call for equality we could
debate that if you want but regardless
meanwhile you have people on the other
side Brian Mast uh a member of Congress
he's a republican he said that there's
no distinction between civilians and
Hamas inside Gaza lindsy Graham said we
should level the place referring to Gaza
you so you have lindsy Graham called for
bombing Iran I'm like wor guy so so you
have people calling for you know mass
murder inside Gaza and openly endorsing
State terrorism saying there's no
distinction between civilians and Hamas
they don't get censured Rashid the one
palestin American member of Congress
does that's the power and balance that I
think speaks to what what's going on
here what does that mean that she was
censured what happened exactly a formal
resolution you censure someone you're
basically reprimanding them for speaking
out of if they do it again they get
fired or something well it it entirely
depends on the speaker it depends on uh
party leadership like a warning it's
like an official warning or something
it's like a it's a demerit it's like we
hear be merch your honor haha and they
sign but they don't lose anything they
just it's just like yeah losing would
have to come from uh an official action
by you like the speaker or or party a
party Me official so censure is is
mostly just like we hereby declare that
you have done a bad thing thing yes we
have agreed you have done wrong however
there is uh when Marjorie Taylor green
got stripped from all her committees and
she got booted so power disparity really
just spend depends on the subject matter
so I know you're specifically referring
to the Israel Palestine and and not
necessarily any other subject matters I
think the issue with this is I got to be
honest man you know these are the rules
that uh Rashid T wants to live by I have
absolutely no problem with her being
censured first of all it doesn't really
do anything she may it may be bad for
her in the long run because clearly
other members of Congress don't like her
if they're willing to censure her but my
attitude when it comes to free speech
has changed a bit from I think it was
very naive 10 years ago to say something
like we must defend the Free Speech even
for those who disagree with us to where
I'm now at I'll defend the free speech
for anybody who defends Free Speech
anybody who opposes Free Speech will get
no defense from me so if Rashid T and
the people she works with are fine with
censorship of other people I will not be
rushing to her defense okay you know
what that's a fair point because you
want moral consistency but I'll defend
anyone's free speech so as someone who
does support that I think it's fair to
oppose her being censored especially if
for trying to be consistent people
saying it's not moral consistency it is
it is if we allow people who oppose free
speech to like if if there are two
forces and one side says I will give you
leeway and the other side says I will
not give you leeway then over a long
enough period of time the the the the
compromising party will lose and this is
actually the argument made by the left
they show that Carl popper meme all the
time about tolerating intolerance I
think that's a little dry but if I
simplify it it's if Rashid T says we
must defend Free Speech defended free
speech on campus denounced the violent
riots and and the attacks on on people
for various opinions I I'd be right now
saying like we must defend rashita TB
because we disagree so for instance like
Cassandra candra McDonald who's a good
friend of mine very critical of Israel
and she's adamantly pro- free speech and
so I'm just like I will absolutely
defend I got but how do you know that
Rashida TBA is not pro Free Speech
because I know of her also defending the
rights of Julian Assange that to me is a
free speech so that's good I haven't
seen any evidence that she's anti-free
speech except for that that that she's a
Democrat which I understand it's fair
enough in these in the in these times to
assume if someone's like a congressional
Democrat they might have some anti-free
speech views I think that's a fair
assumption but in the case of rash I
can't think of any evidence off hand
that she's anti-free speech I mean have
you what have you seen from her just
going back of the past several years
relating to various actions that have
taken place in and around Congress and
various stances and defenses from
Congress pertaining to people like
Margery Taylor green versus Ilan Omar it
is free speech when it's something I
care about and I if I don't care I'm not
involved right okay but but to be fair
it would be prudent of me to before
saying something like that have like a
list of examples but my point isn't
necessarily to single out Rashida T over
this because I don't think she's like a
a un she's like the epitome of a guilty
party when it comes to not being in
support of free speech I agree with him
the Julian Assange stuff and Rashid has
had some several victories in the past
things that I agree with her on as well
I I'm I'm just more
so censorship is not that big of a deal
but I agree with you on the on the power
disparity for sure when it comes to
Israel and mostly because the
military-industrial complex and the
lobbyists in this country absolutely
want yeah conflict War contracts Etc
Lindsey Graham exemplifies it better
than anything else when he says we
should bomb Iran with or without
evidence what's going on in Israel I
don't think you know we we were asking
uh um I forgot who we asked on the show
about it do you think it's religious
because there are some people who are
deeply religious and they've there's
podcasts that have come out where they
say things like this could be the second
or depending on your on your religion
the first coming of the Messiah and so
and I know it sounds crazy and there's a
lot of people who don't believe this
stuff but there are very serious
prominent Christians and Jews who
believe this may be the Messianic era
the red heer Etc I get so pissed about
that cuz for the Israelis to claim it's
a Jewish thing is putting all the Jewish
people's lives at risk across the Earth
it is an Israeli thing but my point was
we asked you know is it religious no no
no at the highest levels it's mostly
just military expansion oil energy Etc
the US has desperately wanted to go to
war with Iran having military assets and
control in Israel is massively massively
beneficial to the US military interests
in the region we it was very difficult
to invade Iraq it was very difficult to
to invade Afghanistan we struggled and
failed in both these countries but in
Israel the United States has a very
power ful military
foothold not the same as I'm not saying
they have massive military bases the
same as you know like Afghanistan I mean
like they don't need it when we are
sending weapons and missiles and funding
and things like that I totally agree
that the US interest is geopolitical and
Israel's been a client state of the us
since 1967 when it showed that it could
smash Arab nationalism and after that
Israel became very favored by the US
bipartisan establishment now though you
do have this phenomenon of these
extremists or of these um you know uh
Evangelical Christians who are a major
base of support for Israel that is
important especially in some
Congressional races and you also have a
pro-israel Lobby too APAC which also can
influence Congressional races with their
sway but the interest has always been
the same it's just because also Israel
has gone so much to the right and has
become the face of it has become so
clear a lot of its former supporters
have turned away from it because it's
it's not as easy as it used to be I mean
I'm I'm Jewish I grew up in the Jewish
Community it used to be hard for people
like me to hold the view which are
critical of Israel now in my circles
nobody nobody defends Israel anymore so
hence they've had to find other bases of
support which isn't the is in the
Evangelical Christian Community I I find
with like the left and the right
spreading out but also now shattering
and like kind of almost like you see
this what's happening is if think of the
left and the right on a globe and it's
all around the equator but it's twisting
up like when tensions get high people
become authoritarian that's going up and
then libertarian would be going down so
you go far to the left but you're also
twisting up becoming more authorit Arian
leftist which is like fight do the thing
the river to the sea or you're going to
the right and getting twisted up into an
authoritarian
rtist smash them all the the nuclear
weapons in Gaza and like or you see the
people's True Colors come out in times
of tension if they become more
libertarian like I'm we should not be
committing more arms to this to escalate
it again and then there's some people
that you know you see the whole globe
and they're like well we're in a
military we're basically controlling
Earth's military right now and Israel's
a big part of that if we let it go
that's going to be loss to the American
Military indust let me let let me tell
you what's really fascinating to me is
uh Rhonda santis he orders the
dissolution of these student groups that
state in their like documents or
whatever that they are not in support of
the movement they are the movement Ron
says that's that said they're asserting
that they're Hamas that they are not
just activists and some of these many of
these people involved did they say we
support the Hamas movement or just the
resistance movement in general they said
the the the the documents I want to be
careful because it did not say
explicitly we are Hamas it said the
people who engaged in these fights are
Freedom Fighters and we are part of that
movement as Palestinians in Exile okay
so so they're saying that they support
resistance but I
mean theis for Palestine I I it was
whatever Ron ban okay Ron's argument was
if you are claiming to be a part of this
movement this group then you can't be a
student group because it violates the
law okay you you can't be actively
trying to support a terrorist
organization you're gone well
interesting is VI ramaswami came out and
said no way these are students engaged
in free speech actually uh uh talked to
him V very briefly and I was like yeah
but did you read it they said they're
not support of the movement they are the
movement and he said students saying
stupid things is not the same thing as
as supplying terrorist organizations are
providing material support Ron should
not be shutting these people down and
then actually on the debate stage said
the same thing I have tremendous respect
for that because VI was not just easily
swayed by this argument many people on
the right who are in support of Israel
were saying like oh yeah but look they
say they are you know they're
effectively saying they are Hamas cuz
that's actually my first instinct was
don't ban the group oh wait they're
saying they're Hamas okay well now it's
getting interesting then V pushes back
and says no way free speech so I think
it's interesting uh I think it's it's
it's Troublesome that we are definitely
seeing there are many people who are
pro-israel that would be on the right
that are not for free speech and I think
we have to be careful of I certainly
think it's more so on the left than the
right but opportunists who would claim
to be for free speech and then at a
moment's notice try and ban the speech
of someone who authoritarian man and you
see it in the In the Heat of the Moment
I don't want to put you know I really
don't want to put Shapiro on blast Ben I
love you return my phone calls then I'll
stop putting you on blast um no I
haven't actually called him yet but like
it shocked me how how quickly he was
screaming about annihilating a bunch of
humans after his and I fear can do that
to somebody you know and if he was when
you're the military commander you don't
have what do you mean by that he came
out pretty early on I don't want to put
words in his mouth but he was very much
like we need a swift strong counter
offensive and we need to put this to bed
basically saying Ben's been pretty
adamant that uh uh the killing of
civilians is a tragedy the difference
between him and and the typical left is
that he's in support of uh Israel's
military actions which is resulting in a
lot of Civilian dead his argument and I
I don't I don't mean to argue for him he
can speak for himself but his argument
is more so that there's a difference
between Hamas flying over and targeting
people at a music f
and Israel targeting military leaders
and killing civilians in the process
however he has also said the killing of
any civilian is a tragedy uh the daily
uh Jeremy boring also said the death of
any Palestinian civilian woman or child
as well as Israeli are tragedies in an
equal sense so I'm not trying to defend
what Ben is saying I'm trying to clarify
his position he's not saying just go
around kill the way he came out and said
it I guess it was the day of or the day
after the attack October 8th or was it
the 9th when he spoke out publicly about
it like there I didn't didn't see him
talking about like well what happened
why was the why did the attack happen
for 6 hours why was there no IDF
response in six hours of of this just
raping and pillaging that these these
Hamas members were doing why was there
no defense I didn't hear any of that
from Ben it was just very much like we
need to go in they've done it to us now
get them and it was like I don't that
was a quick twist to authoritarian and
if he had his finger on the button
that's that's a temper I don't like I my
view would be a very simple if someone
attacks you stop them bring them to
justice however I can see the arguments
that are happening now are much much
much different right uh you know your
video you're talking about seire I think
the amount of Destruction that's that
that's happening in Gaza is is is is
exceeding what I would describe as uh
proportional yeah I yes um I'm trying to
keep it very very very plain if you can
tell yeah the uh acatic line you have to
say uh if you support Israel is that
Israel has a right to defend itself and
in the abstract yeah of course uh
someone has a right to defend themselves
but what do we mean by that defense so
if this is October 7th and they're being
attacked by Hamas absolutely you have
the right to defend yourself but this
isn't October 7th anymore now this is a
month-long operation a carpet bombing of
Gaza as we're speaking more than 11,000
killed more than 4600 children I got I
got to push back onp yeah technically I
think it's not technical carpet bombing
because it's targeting specific areas
and then there's just collateral damage
carpet bombing would be targeting
massive bombing of a densely populated
area it it it is yes massive absolutely
and what's missing from this discussion
is an acknowledgement that uh before
October 7th things weren't all peachy
for Israel's been occupying Gaza and the
West Bank for decades since 1967 and
what is Gaza majority of it is refugees
and their descendants people who are
expelled ethnically cleansed by Israel
in
1948 and a country that is occupying
someone else doesn't have the right to
defend itself in order to perpetuate
that occupation if they're being
attacked on October 7th I understand you
defend your your people but after that
Israel's only obligation is to end the
occupation they don't have the they
don't have the right to bomb people uh
because they live in an area where some
militants fought back thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. and become a
member over at
timcast.net shows exclusive thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time